on voit les gens des scouts du pot on
passe nos temps hors ligne c'est pas
pareil désormais considéré comme
commerce est essentiel les boutiques
culturelles peuvent rester ouverte
pendant le confinement un refuge pour
les clients pour la notion de culture
c'est vrai que ma part ces temps de
confinement peut avoir envie de se
retrouver s'évader justement par la
lecture pour avoir une sensation de
bien-être
les clients sont là on est content parce
que effectivement on avait un petit peu
peur mais ils sont là après il
transforme un petit peu leurs habitudes
d'achat parce que du coup ils passent
beaucoup plus part de la réservation a
pour limites et effectivement le temps
qu'ils peuvent passer en magasin pas de
peinture pas de produits dérivés pas de
déco dans les grandes enseignes jeu
vidéo disquaires librairies sont
épargnés on vend beaucoup de liseuses il
c'est vrai que c'est bien parce que ça
ne remplace pas le livre papier c'est
vraiment un complément c'est une manière
différente de lire donc voilà ça c'est
plutôt chouette aussi et ça prouve qu'il
ya aussi beaucoup de gens qui sont remis
à la lecture pendant le premier confie
non ça c'est plutôt bon signe pour la
culture les libraires constate également
un changement de fréquentation dans leur
aller avec un public parfois plus jeunes
on voit en effet des jeunes
des collégiens des lycéens qui viennent
faire des achats et le week-end c'est
beaucoup plus fort c'est vraiment une
catégorie de gens qui fréquentent très
bien la librairie nous sommes très
heureux que c'est vrai que le dernier
point de chute qui reste c'est c'est la
librairie
voilà quoi donc les gens se réfugient là
dans le bon sens du terme
voilà un soulagement pour le secteur du
livre qui avait déjà limité les dégâts
en 2020 avec un recul de seulement 3,3
pour cent de son chiffre d'affaires